it's the pride of New Hampshire the man
from Manchester the comic from Concord
we actually have no idea what city are
from Seth Meyers but we do know you went
to the most important and best
university in America Northwestern
University and a proud graduate of West
High well in Manchester I came close
very good thank you for coming I want to
start with some New Hampshire trivia oh
great let's go
Gracie how well you know you guys don't
do well yeah state fruit state fruit
snowball pumpkin pumpkin okay
state insect state insect black fly
ladybug okay state sport state sports
easier is hockey skiing okay let me ask
you this is not that's not trivial let's
get serious
okay what I'm two for three okay that's
not what actually kind of do you think
it's like New Hampshire's got an
outsized importance in presidential
politics yeah do you think that's right
fair and proper I don't I think it's
pretty foolish that they it's the same
two states Iowa New Hampshire every
election that sort of set the tone I
would be a lot happier if they sort of
rotated it around with that said I do
think we have people from New Hampshire
take it very seriously and you know and
I'm one of the benefits of a small state
obviously is I do think most of the
voters get a chance to meet the
candidates in a way you can't on a
larger state but I certainly I would not
be upset even though obviously a lot of
people my home state would be I would
not be upset if they switched it up I
want to be clear just after offering
that answer you're not going to be
welcome back in the state after that
that's fine did you intersect a lot with
the primary when you were growing up
were you there when muskie cry I wasn't
there but we you know I was I graduated
high school in 92 and every single
candidate that year came through I
actually introduced Jerry Brown on stage
because I was in the student council
because they would all of that somewhere
I don't know I don't I know I got to
wear a plaid shirt instead of a coat and
tie because it was Jerry Brown
I saw Clinton speak that year and yeah
everybody came to work on campaigns were
you oh and I mean I was too cool know
who else know but I never worked on any
campaigns but it was great when it I
mean that was the nice thing about
growing up there's you were very aware
of how the politics worked so we showed
you doing a bunch of interviews with yes
center cares what do you do to get ready
for an interview like that well it's
funny because you bone up more than you
would for you know someone who has a
movie or someone who has a television
show also because you want very
you find it very important to be
intelligent and you you want to project
information to the audience because
that's the only reason to have
candidates on I will say it's hard and
maybe you guys will learn this as well
if you ask a candidate a question they
will talk the whole time unless you
interrupt them they kind of do the lean
in think we say yeah if you notice I'll
and as that classic clip package when
there was yeah I was anything more
farther and farther forward all right
let me run through some of the
candidates that you've interviewed yeah
just give us like your one sense
thumbnail okay got your like right here
we go John Kasich John Kasich seems like
a very nice man but you know I don't
know if the electoral college right now
I was looking for a reasonable man okay
Ted Cruz Ted Cruz I found him a very
aggressive debater he was more
interesting than most of my guests
because he was very willing to go back
and forth I think he's very used to that
you can tell he he likes conflict and
that made him an interesting guest
Carly Fiorina Carly Fiorina was sharp
but maybe a little bit less charismatic
than I was expecting
really yeah but I found her to be very
shy so I just felt a talk show guest I
didn't find it to be wowed
I'd never out but I feel like when
people run for president they have to
have a little bit more sparkle maybe
okay and last mr. Sparkle senator Graham
Lindsey Graham Lindsey was all sparkling
a zombie show nothing's like a 1% like
what you're pulling at 1% you kind of
come on late-night he was dealing he had
a lot of jabs he had some Jew loaded up
jokes I think you could always tell when
they they pre-planned their off-the-cuff
joke I can't believe you forgot Bernie
Sanders though how about that Bernie
Sanders look he's got a good sense of
humor it was very laid-back
it was fun to talk to so I we've done
some reporting ok as we are want to do
and we're told by sources familiar with
you thinking that your dream interview
was with Vladimir Putin would love to
get him on the show a great
impressionist so here's so here's the
piers we're gonna do a little practice
right now okay I need to be Vladimir
Putin okay ready yeah mr. Seth Mouse
it's very good to meet you okay before
we send you to the labor camp okay what
would you like to know about me well I
should let you know
Vladimir it's a the way the culture of
talk shows in our country where cuz I
ask few questions I feel like you've
right away you sort of stolen this away
from me
this is I'm not a guest on your show
this isn't Crimea this is Late Night
with Seth Meyers you can't just take
this
you know if you took up at this point if
I were blind rebooting my [ __ ] off yeah
and then you'd be done yeah all right
being funny is important to get elected
right like when Clint Obama and Bush all
had moments of late-night try yes right
all of them deaths so Jeb Bush what's
the funniest thing about em well I don't
know what say it is different now than I
feel like it's ever been before as far
as how important is to be funny because
there's so many talk shows we all enjoy
having these people on as guests
there's you know in a weird way the
markets a little bit saturated I feel
like you know for all their best efforts
I don't know if anybody was gonna have
some late-night moments gonna elevate
them Hillary on SNL I think Hillary won
SNL was the best is is it does it rate
when you have them on to those shows yes
I mean certainly I mean I remember you
know the SNL one of my biggest S&L
memories was in Sarah Palin came on in
2008 and that was the highest rated show
in decades and you know we'll see if
that'll be the case when doctor Pataki
episode I think Pataki was a very big
fellow